what shirt do you wear brother small
yeah and how does that feel on you does
it feel
tight feels good what a little tight but
good
amen brother all right today's episode
is brought to you by
grey block pizza gray block pizza 1811
pico boulevard
on the way to the beach grey block get
that hitter baby
you know i really i live between them i
live kind of between uh
i live in a lot i kind of go with a
large shirt and
sometimes i want to be in an xl
you know i want to just be in an xl i
want people to see me and be like oh
yeah he wears an xl
you know i want the ladies to see me and
say oh yeah that's an xl fella that's a
real
you know that's a stallion or something
because i feel sometimes like a little
you know
i mean i was so excited when i got from
a medium to an l i was
i remember i bought myself a damn can of
beer when i
when i did it you know when i got from
that medium to that l i remember getting
myself a damn cold kind of beer and
god i just felt like i had made it
you know and and some people you know
your size you run out of size you know
god only gives you so much size and you
run out of
you know you know he doesn't give you
enough yarn to keep sewing yourself
bigger and bigger
and so you run out and you kind of uh
you know you're stuck with the quilt
that you are and
and you're always i feel like as a man
you're always kind of hoping to get to
those other levels you know the
to the s to the m to the l to that xl
and the double xl that's true that's
really
that feels like tricky territory
to me riley what do you think about that
yeah i think you're totally right
and did you ever go from an xs to an s
i have and what was that like for you
ah it was a change yeah did you feel
do you remember when it was i think it
was around sixth grade
six seventh god it's beautiful man
and what happened your bones grew out or
something they did
and did you remember people noticing did
you notice did you feel any different
yeah i i felt a lot different i felt a
lot better
and do you think will you ever get to an
m do you think you're headed there you
feel it coming on
so sometimes i wear m's um oh really i
do depends what type
of shirt okay so big dog
getting out and about huh yeah seems so
things things are changing for you bucko
i love that i love hearing that i love
hearing people get
to new levels all right let's see what
we can do here
welcome to this past weekend
a long time ago
i was in love with the girl
and i think i took that love a little
too far
[Music]
you can see the cigarette buttons on the
wall come on
and all the empty bottles in the hall
[Music]
if the water gets too rough you know who
to call
you baby
[Music]
and i can see the way it looks in your
eyes i can see it baby
i'm so so lost with his foolish life
if you ever have to ask baby i'm
surprised
i'm so surprised
[Music]
[Music]
little black flies
and that is 89 volt and that's a new hit
they got there that new raw
that new soul ringer right there 89 volt
coming in hard
coming in hard like an erect garbage man
baby
and doing what he do collecting things
baby that's it right there
man little black little
black flies that'll get you get
that that'll get it for you right there
and that's off that album i think little
black flies i believe is the name of
their album that's 89 volt
good to be here with you today um
you know i've been watching uh the
olympics i just went out of town
you know i tend to travel and i remember
when i was young uh
the first place i ever went a friend of
mine a neighbor
and this fella was haunted man
this fella was haunted brother and his
uh little gerald was this boy
and he was he had a deficiency or
something when he would
say something he would say it again
under his breath real quick you know
um he would be like yeah i'm going uh
i'm going to get me a lime soda i'm
going to get me a lime soda
he would say things twice and people
thought that he was
twins that had never separated
you know people said oh he got another
one in there and
god never divvied him up at birth and
so he's doubled up in there and other
people said it's just an echo you know
he gots a big
he gets a wide throat so when he says
something one time then you just hear it
another time hear it another
time so there's all these different
rumors and speculations you know
but i i you know when i see gerald he he
would just say you know he would say
something to you and then he would say
something
he'd be like man i got to go home it's
lunch time i got to go home
you know he just had that double up on
him he had that reverb that heavy
he had that heavy uh ver that audio
bounce inside of him
you know just just double dribbling all
of his syllables and consonants and
every word
you know god was just double dribbling
on it
and the first time i ever went anywhere
i remember his his mom was
uh and mama was fat
and i hate to say it like that and she
was
she wasn't like she didn't have like a
beer belly and look
we all come in different sizes
and i think there's advantages and
disadvantages to all of them
and his mama was just warm like a damn i
mean she just
i think she worked at a hospital or at a
either that or she just wore she might
have just worn men's clothing i don't
know what she did she just
she always had matching pant suit top
and bottom
so she could have been a nurse or she
could have been a damn
you know she kind of dressed like a
black guy you know matching pants and
shirt
you know what i'm talking about riley i
do
and anyway she was so warm she was a big
lady she kind of
you know and i i i shouldn't have said
she's fat i mean and i don't mean it
like that like
degrading or i just mean she's a you
know she was just she had extra
and that's the kind of woman she was she
had a little extra hug for you she had a
little extra
love she had an extra you know whisper
in your ear if you needed she had a
little extra sandwich
if you needed a meat on a bread she had
it for you
i don't remember her name i don't
remember her name when she and she died
she did die
eventually i'm not sure what happened
but
she really uh she wore like a gold chain
as well she dressed honestly like a
brother
she dressed like you know kind of like a
crayola crayon with a gold chain on
you know a lot of time you'll see a
black gentleman have orange pants
orange shirt orange orange leggings
orange
shirt orange sunglasses of a full
dichotomy of one color
you know um anyway they took me one time
to
i guess it was a campground i thought it
was in mississippi
mississippi america and if you haven't
been there
you're it's very much like uh
it's like reading tom sawyer but
with your time with your lot with your
body and
and your time it's like basically
wandering around inside of tom sawyer
you know you see people that don't even
don't even believe don't even know about
certain things you tell people
you know about the 21st century i don't
even believe you
you know people too busy you know
drinking
sweet tea and just kind of
you know putting teeth under their
pillow hoping for the best kind of vibe
but anyway so we went there and that was
the first place i'd ever traveled to the
first my first experience getting out
and they took me over there to
mississippi and
and uh we went swimming in some type of
hell i don't know what it was it could
have been that they i think it was some
type of a river or something
and uh and they had a snake in there and
i was so scared
and and we stayed in these trailer homes
and we ate bologna sandwiches
and if you haven't had bologna i mean
it's like uh it's like a damn
have you had it riley now bologna meat i
have and what was your experience with
it like how would you describe it
um it's more like a type of ham
i would say okay
you look that up for us tell us a little
bit more about it if you can
and i remember we had it and we had just
american cheese on these buns and
some type of condiment on there could
have been mayonnaise could have been
white
mustard i think they came out briefly
with a white mustard that never took
off because i think people were
squirting it on each other and saying it
was
you know ejac or semen or whatever you
know all kids will be
but uh anyway what do you got riley any
intel on it
yeah it's a meat batter so beef pork
turkey chicken
or all of the above damn so that's a
damn charlotte's web gang bang right
there you know what i'm saying baby
that's everything i mean if you
i mean that's really just like taking a
damn farm and putting it in a blender
and then pouring it right into your body
or into your buddy's body
but anyway that was the first time that
ever traveled and that's where i went
and
since then i've continued to travel i've
been a traveling man and
you know this past weekend i went up to
um
[Music]
minogue mynonk
minnesota can you look at it for me
minok
ming naan i think ming naan like
for like filet mignon mingnon minnesota
what does it say
there's a top 10 best filet mignon in
minnesota
all righty man but this place was called
i think um
i think mignon minnesota i'm not sure it
could have been called mignon but
i went up there and man i went up there
jimmy john invited me
and you guys know jimmy john the
sandwich monarch he's that turkey tom
kingpin
you know that's who he is and he invited
me up there and he does a summer camp
with
all of his friends he invites all type
of friends and humans
and um
and we and and i got to go and man flew
up there on a private plane
fancy plane beautiful i mean god even
the air smelled like
you you'd inhale and just you knew a
couple stock tips
you know you just i mean damn you clear
your throat and find
some cryptocurrency in it you know just
living high on the hog
baby like somebody put a ladder on a
damn pig's back
and i went up that man i was living high
on the hog
so we took that did the jimmy john jet
up there
oh sorry man i got got a little bit of
bitcoin i think they're still stuck in
my throat from the experience
um but we went up there and it was
awesome he literally
he literally treats his friends to a
summer camp in the summer
and it's adults and children and
childish adults and adulterous kids
you know autism and everything man
there's people up there and
uh you know the of
travis tritt came and played the
american country music icon who
really has a voice like somebody stuffed
three black dudes right into his
esophagus
you know and one black woman i mean he
gots all the
you know he he hits the notes baby
um a band called jj gray
uh who else zach brown band came up and
played and man
they got so many hits dude you could
have a concussion
just from listening to them but it was
awesome they had sea dues and jet skis i
went
fishing caught a uh sturgeon or a little
baby sturgeon or something
caught me a little carp a little bit of
lake carp
or sunfish or brim or uh
sockalay speckle tr there's so many
names for this one
fish that comes out of a lake that it's
just
you know it's one little fish and
there's so many names for it you know
white fish soccer perch brim
sunfish um
uh you know white koi
uh and white koi was also
also the name of every wigger dude in in
any community any kind of white dude
that wanted to be black wig uh
they would his name was coy usually and
he wore north carolina jersey baby
praise god no
but what are we talking about man i went
fishing we went see uh
c doing jet skiing watched fireworks
had a nice little cabin they had some
brand new cabins they had a gym
man it was it just made me
one of the things that was cool it was
like if you have some extra currency
one great way to spend it is doing
something fun with your friends
instead of saving that money just saving
it all or
for what you know
so anyway it was i got to i met clint
boyer
and he is a um he drove nascar
you know who that is riley mao i don't
you watch a lot of nascar
or not they allow that in your you
guys's deal
uh a little bit yeah
i guess it's all bumper to bumper in and
y'all's culture huh
it is have you um what was your first
car raleigh
it was a honda accord oh yeah i had one
they're good huh yeah they're reliable
they are reliable god
my first car was a ford escort i don't
know if they still have they might have
discontinued them because of
fire hazards and a couple other small
issues they had but
uh they um
one of them you could put a motorcycle
tire on the
on it if you ran out of regular tires or
the ability to get to a tire
to tire up
so you could do that baby and then i
remember we could you know sometimes
we wouldn't be able to sleep anywhere we
we so we popped a couple of uh
we chiseled a couple holes into the
back of the hatch back and put some uh
plastic tubing out of them and you could
just you know you have to kind of keep
your mouth on the tube but you could
sleep in the back then and just breathe
out
through in and out of the outside
interesting so pretty cool
stuff but anyway i had a great time went
up there caught some fish
caught some uh just caught some joy
i mean just staying up laughing i mean
they had some
rednecks up there and white necks and
black necks and
uh they had one dude had no neck on him
you know a necklace dude just straight
up shoulders to brain you know
just dude i mean he just wore his
thoughts on his sleeve you know that
kind of felon
um and if you're watching on youtube we
got a lot of i'll put a lot of
you know edits in of uh we'll put some
photos in different times from the
weekend
um but i got to go on this little can-am
car
it's like this uh can you pull up a
picture of that do you mind really
can-am
c-a-n-a-m
this it's like a four-wheeler
looks like a big cricket kind of but
with wheels instead of legs
and it's a fierce deal and i got to go
racing on that with clint boyer's
and if you for not familiar with clint
boyer's he's a
and i wasn't either i never met the man
or
knew about him i believed he could exist
but i never knew actually i'd heard his
name but i'd never met him
so i didn't know he existed i just heard
his name
and he took me out on that you see it i
do
interesting how would you describe it i
think it's an atv
atv there you go or it used to be atv i
don't know what it is now i mean they
remodeled it i mean it's a vehicle now
right but at one time yeah i guess it
could have been a damn tv but
i mean this [ __ ] had all the bells and
whistles you know and
and we got out there and we went on
these off-road trails and when you're
riding with a real man who is a nascar
man
you know a guy who i mean this dude
probably he'll drink gas and then just
regurgitate it into his tank if he needs
to get that extra lap
you know what i'm saying he will uh
siphon out of his own body for that
extra
you know that last leader um
yeah it was just a whirlwind so
but it's just it was cool man it was
cool and
uh kid rock was up there the freaking
the methadone mascot of america
basically
and he's up there and he got a beautiful
brother that only got
one leg beautiful fella named billy
one-legged guy
and beautiful and i swear to god if i
had a brother if i had as much money as
kid rock does and i had a brother with
one leg
i'll tell you this i'd get him another
leg but
that ain't how uh
that ain't no k rock spends his cash i
guess he does things different so praise
god baby
um what else is going on uh
but yeah i was just thankful man i you
know it's just interesting you meet you
meet a guy jimmy john through the
podcast and then
he invites you on a fun weekend and just
reminds you
it was just a nice to be around people
you know i'm not around people very much
you know i'm
my job is very solitude very solitudish
you know it's solamente that's spanish
for
just me and so to get to be around
people and laugh
and you know some kid try to buy drugs
off me and
and you know just that's you know that's
america baby
you know that's america man
and the best part was i said to the kid
i said look man i can't sell drugs to
you
you know if you're not you know if
you're in my family and you're a child
i'll consider it more but
you know this is a child that's not in
my family and
and he said well look man they're not
for me they're i'm gonna i'm gonna
resell them
and and that's america man
that's america baby you gotta respect
that
but that was a beautiful time maybe a
little bit of prime rib
it's a couple hot cake in the morning
and it was good man he was smooth got me
a little smooching on
you know touching face with some other
with some feminine deal you know a
little baby out there little baby dragon
sucking face with a little bit with a
little baby dragon
out there raleigh mal how's the update
with you with the ladies
uh not going that well damn
yeah well we got a lot of calls that
have come in today about
you know last episode you weren't here
we talked about the first time i
that i'd ever ejaculated out of my body
you know
and just lost that tug of war with the
devil you know and uh
so we got a lot of beautiful young men
or i don't know if they're beautiful but
i assume that they are on the inside
who have called in who will be sharing
some of their stories
and uh so we'll get into that you
remember your first time bucko
uh no no never happened really you've
never masturbated
no oh my gosh brother
wow man what is that called is that what
do you guys call that
nothing really there's got to be a
special nickname i think in
gay culture if it's a man in gay culture
a guy that's never kissed a woman is
called a golden oreo
i wonder what that is my god brother
damn you just have just baby's breath
inside of your
nuts right now that is damn beautiful
brother congratulations man
thank you you think you'll be able to
hold the line are you trying to hold the
line until marriage you think or just
until a relationship
yeah until marriage wow
good for you brother and do you feel
like you have more of an inner strength
going on
i do yeah
you know i had breakfast with a guy a
couple weeks ago and he'd never
masturbated and i
i was just so jealous
because the rest are because i
masturbated honestly less than
probably 11 hours ago or 12 hours ago
i couldn't get to sleep and i just felt
the devil just climbing up and down my
penis and i just had to do something
when you get that feeling what do you do
just chill out put your hands on ice or
what
um i don't really get the feeling damn
now what if you get erection in your
body what do you do
can't say i get that either what really
oh my god
oh and do you think you have you might
have an iron deficiency or something or
do you think it's just
no i think i just contain it damn
you like damn chun li bruh
god god
dude how far can you jump i bet you
could jump down 11 feet huh
i wish i bet if you tried hard you could
man
unbelievable the unjackable riley mao
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for being here today brother
thanks for having me i didn't know that
man
i did not know i was sitting here
with just a man that was riding that
paste baby all the way to the finish
line
because yeah i struggle with it man i
just
i do good and then i just struggle you
know
but i hate just jerking out i hate it
but what do you say to people out there
who are considering it or on the fence
about masturbation
um i mean i would say do as you please
but
i wouldn't recommend it i'm one of those
few guys that wouldn't recommend it wow
and do you know other people who are
like you just like a damn human
christmas carol
i do you do wow
and do you all meet up somewhere or
something do you are you guys in a group
chat
um not really group chat but you guys
know who each other are
right damn
you know i've always it's like a super
power
it is a super everybody wants to be iron
man
you know but iron man
you know he ain't nutting out at night
he ain't and they're making macadamians
in his bedroom
you know so there is a lot of power and
cheering up
cheese up hoes down baby you know what
i'm saying
i do you do dang so do you ever think
about the long
road you have to hoe before you're gonna
get to some uh
you know some you know skeet that's what
they call it in the urban community
yeah it comes across my mind a few times
damn
i almost want to be there when it
happens brother no homo you know
i'll invite you well come on now that
might be a bit
you know but maybe i'll be outside if
there's a window or something i want to
be right up front
man i got to tell you guys
all the way from australia to houston
there's a body hair problem
and that is true thankfully manscaped
has you cleared for takeoff with their
fourth generation brand new lawnmower
if you have body hair you can get rid of
it that's right but the performance
package 4.0 join the two million men
worldwide who trust manscaped
i trust manscaped okay i do trust them
get your rocket ready for takeoff by
going to manscape.com
theo for 20 often free shipping yup
you'll get the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker
ear and nose trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant it's a little bit of
toner
she could tone them bad hangers up and
some performance blocker
boxer briefs get 20 off and free
shipping go to manscape.com
theo and support the podcast and support
your body
it's a great way to clear hair and dirt
off your body with
manscaped look i gotta tell you if
you're carrying a
credit card balance each month well
it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt
upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get ahead
man credit card payment will keep you
down i remember i was 27 000
in debt one day and i didn't know what
to do and i wasn't doing
anything i remember i was just listening
to to nirvana and just pleasuring myself
but thankfully that changed many
americans experienced financial hardship
in the last year
well upstart can help you regain your
footing
and get things back on track what's this
thing called
upstart find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com
t-h-e-o that's
r u-p-s-t-a-r-t dot com slash theo
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
t-h-e-o
yeah you've been watching the olympics
rally
uh just a little bit okay and you have a
favorite sport what are you guys
in your culture is there a favorite
sport over there
i like hockey oh really
what is it about it uh i don't know it's
just more engaging
and fun in my opinion yeah
so and it's this is summer olympics so
they don't have it right right
so you're just watching and looking for
but they don't have it i've done that
yeah i've done that before someone will
watch basketball and just wish it was
football the whole time
but i'll keep watching um
a couple of news stories out of the
olympics a belarusian sprinter
christina simeone
simanuskaya was granted a polish
humanitarian
visa while seeking political asylum
after she refused to board a flight
back to her home country from the tokyo
games this is pretty wild man her home
country
wanted her to wanted to pull her out of
the olympic games
and so she asked for help on instagram
uh and here she is right here here's her
statement
and she asked the olympic internation
the international olympic committee to
get involved and help her out
you know her own country didn't like
some of the ways she was representing
them
and they they said this is a no-go
we're gonna pull you out of here and uh
and she didn't want that so she asked
for help while she was away from belarus
she asked for help
and so now poland came along polish
power
and they're letting her drop over there
into warsaw
and you know this is the type of thing
this to me
is an act of
like speaking out against types of
oppression
you know this to me is you know you have
a
we've had a different american um
olympians you know they have some new
lady the other day
she got it looks like a piece of king
cake her hair is kind of died up and
she you know just talking about
oppression from the metal stand i don't
even think she won first place either i
think she was silver
first of all i think you should be you
should have to get first place to
to talk about the oppression and also if
you're in america
there's no there's not oppression
i don't feel like there's oppression you
know i've met people from every race and
every
gender and even animals look at air bud
dude in some countries you know no
offense for you know riley mal but in
some countries dude that
you know you go to some of these more
like kennel snacking continents and
things would be different that thing's a
movie star over here
you know so when a lot of these people
are just talking about oppression
but they're literally standing in a
place where they're able to say whatever
they want
and can still go back to their own
country
i think it's a perfect example of uh
seeing her
this is a real example of what like
oppression
and control uh by our country really
looks like
what do you think riley on any of this
have you seen any of this you don't know
about it
i haven't okay
um but yeah i think i'm just over the
you know the look at me when you're
living in an amazing life it's really
hard
to uh to say that the
place you're living it in the platform
you're living it in is oppressing you
i mean i think we all feel somewhat
pressured
and struggle through society
but there needs to be struggle
for everyone there needs to be some
pressure
[Music]
but yeah uh this is this is
something that is real when now you
can't even go back home
because you spoke freely i bet if that
was the case
for some of the american athletes uh i
bet that they
would have a different a understanding
of oppression and then be a different
tone
i think but what do i know you know what
i'm saying i'm just one human
who's ejaculated less than 11 hours ago
so and not really proud of it
you know um
what else man what else is going on uh
lobuci
he's been on the pod you know that and
he had a he had a little
speech he gave about homosexuality being
pushed
he said how y'all trying to force this
this gay stuff on the world bro
it's sad how y'all trying to ban artists
y'all sad bro it's sad bro
you know in 10 years it ain't gonna be
normal for a kid to be straight
you know it's sad bro y'all trying to
force it on
on on these kids bro you know
you pushing it on the artist push it on
all the biggest artists you know why
because the kids love those artists
you're attacking these kids the kids
love these artists
so we're gonna make all of them promote
this [ __ ] we're gonna make all them
promoted
and who gonna follow the kids
it's sad bro
it's sad bro little boosie speaking out
of one thing i love about laboose he's
always a
he's always willing to share what his
real thoughts are
you know and it's something i i struggle
to do man i think a lot of us struggle
to do that in today's
society with a for a fear of retaliation
you know and most of my fear of
retaliation
you know comes sometimes from
uh you know just that i won't be able to
have opportunities on certain platforms
i'll be de-platformed it's pretty
it's pretty scary you know that
here we are you know
america like uh how it even got started
people wanted to think their own way
and think something that was against the
norm and say stuff that was against
the norm so they left
in a boat but now there's no new place
to go to
um
there's no you can't just get in a boat
and go to a new america
canada's not even letting people in
right now they're still dealing with the
first covet or whatever i don't know
what they're doing
you know and i wish somebody would go
help them out because they're you know i
get so many dms from people in canada
like jesus christ
come help us out you know they found
five
people with covid in a snow bank
somewhere
up near you know up in saskatchewan
and so now the rest of us can't go see
our grandparents for another year
but lobuci look man they definitely
it feels like there is a lot of times an
agenda
this bigger picture agenda
you know like being straight is
definitely
feels like it's
like it is frowned upon
or it is it's not right
um i i agree in all
in some of the sense that a lot of times
they want to create a lot of uncertainty
and kids
and that's who who who consumes a lot of
stuff and who really believes a lot of
things that they see through media
you know you got eight-year-old children
now saying that they're
they may be gay or or they are gay and
you're like well
you might be but i wouldn't it might be
a little early to call the horse race
and it's wild man the media is wild on
all fronts
you know i think anyway the media has
just gotten out of control
i think the media has created a lot of
problems with the covid thing a lot of
you know nobody knows if they can trust
a news source anymore
and i believe it's just because you
can't
the news wins if we're all fighting if
we're all sitting there in
fear of covid watching the news to get
the next dose of whatever they want to
say then that's how they win
especially now when there's like
different news channels and
some of them don't even feel a merit
like it feels like
some of them just i don't know like they
just look so down upon america where
it which is the country you're allowed
to even have the freedom of speech in it
it's all kind of baffling to me am i am
i losing you here riley no
i'm here what do you think on some of
this do you think sometimes the media
kind of
or that like a lot of stuff is
anti-straight or do you think there's
any of that going on what do you what
what are you guys hearing on your end of
it of the horn
honestly i don't really listen to the
news that much anymore just because a
lot of it's fake
yeah and i don't either i think i just
get fearful when i see people who do
sometimes you know that's almost real
scary to me is meeting somebody who
believes the news but then also
if you don't have the news all you have
is that inner news your instincts
and and they're not really letting
people live by those anymore
it feels like it's getting real dicey
out there but i applaud a little boosie
for speaking his mind
you know a lot of a lot of media a lot
of television and
movies these days mostly movies have
gotten really bad because everything's
so woke
it's the most it's just like every
character is
gay or trans or has you know they have a
ghost now they have two gay ghosts i saw
the other day somewhere
doing something they're not scaring
people because it's wrong it's like
you're a [ __ ]
ghost you're a ghost
your job is to do scaring
okay i don't need a ghost
two ghosts you know to
open up a you know a cat rescue
you know what i'm saying that's not your
job is to be ghosting
so it's just getting different out there
it's getting a little dicey out there
uh let's get to a little more news and
then we'll get to uh
get to what else is going on the wuhan
lab you know that's coming out that they
say that they've
you know a uh a
federal committee has determined that
there's a lot of evidence that
believes the mainstream media was silent
on alarming findings from the house
foreign affairs committee
uh a probe into the possible ordinances
of covet 19 on monday
despite one lawmaker calling it the
greatest cover-up in human history
look a lot of people have thought that
that's where the disease came from
so i don't think i think this is just an
example of
the news puts out what it wants to put
out
and so they're now shaping what you
believe which you know
and that's what's scary
that's what's scary is that the media
can shape what we
what we know
and what we believe they always have i
feel like there used to be a sense that
you could trust
them but now there's not that sense so
of course you're gonna have every
you're gonna have people believing
things you're gonna have people
uncertain what to believe
you can have people trust in their
instincts
that's kind of where i'm at man
that's kind of where i'm at one other
thing i noticed the if you look at the
olympic medals
the three leading countries are uh
china america and russia
which i think is just kind of
fascinating because those kind are kind
of like the countries that have
that keep getting like spit around as
um like at each other's throats kind of
or influencing each other's policies or
having an effect on each other's
policies or
tariffing each other or boycotting each
other um
so i just it's almost like
it's just it makes it's like if there's
some sort of bigger power
some new world order that's moving
things around
then it makes sense that now in the
olympics
these are the three countries that are
uh
the metal leaders that are kind of
against each other it's almost like
it's just building the plot more and
more
you know just the accusation of russia
infecting american politics and
uh the issues with the the virus coming
from china
and the denial of it uh by
by um some american media and american
politics
it's just interesting that these are the
three that are in the olympics and it's
neck and neck and
i don't know you know get a glock and a
little bit of property i think if you
can
i feel like because it seems like it's
spooky sometimes
like you don't know when they're gonna
turn this this switch up even higher
and the grill under all of our feet is
gonna get a little bit
gonna get a little bit wicked
but maybe that's all crazy what do you
think riley mao do you think i'm making
any sense or nothing
yeah no you make perfect sense dang
and now this is coming from an oracle
this is coming from the beautiful little
filipino oracle right here
the undaunted the un br
the unbustable riley mao will call you
man
we gotta find you a decent girlfriend
don't we yeah we do
now can you date legally and everything
yeah yeah
we'll have to see if we can find a
decent lady for you what's your
instagram handle riley
it is at rileymouthfilms at riley mao
films so ladies if you're a decent lady
who is willing to you know
be that bust hunter that filipino bust
hunter then you can go after this young
fella right there and
and i don't you feel like i'm auctioning
you off i don't want to be doing that no
please do
okay there you go and there you go
speaking is real mine
the lobusi of our uh studio right here
actually you know what real quick we got
a video of somebody losing it in a
waffle house let's see that
hey get over this counter you're going
to jail
and this is a couple of cute white girls
actually enjoying
some what looks to be let me rewind that
i think that was
uh potato
potato
and while a couple of aggressive you're
not enough aggressive but a couple of
urban women
and one of the women wearing complete
lime outfit
lime coloring so that is kind of a thing
in the urban community you'll see a lot
of full
color lime while
these people enjoy a bit of potato here
a couple dimes here patotting up
while uh a couple
other people not handling society very
well at that moment
and there you go and somebody just
trying to work and
somebody to know how to be a societal
person right there and that's
it's always tough you ever been in a
place where they had a fight in the
establishment riley
actually yeah just recently where were
you at
um i was at one of the bars in downtown
nashville oh wow so you go out to the
bars though i do
okay and what type of places do you
enjoy when you go out do you enjoy a bit
of music do you enjoy a bit of just uh
people sitting around telling tales or
what um yeah either like you know live
shows that
artists in nashville go to and perform
or
like edm raves oh okay damn
now that feels like it'd be risking that
you know risking that body nut taking
your body an
unexploded body out to an edm ray
because there's a lot of sexy outfits
out there
uh not for me damn what do you just
drink cold water the other time
do you hold ice in your hands what do
you do um
sometimes water but beer as well oh
really you'll have some beer
dang and that's really man that's right
that's getting on the bull said how do
you have beer and not
masturbate your body off um i just drink
beer to have a good time
damn god i need god
i need god man
[Music]
oh i just can't stay off that bus stick
recently but uh
anyway speaking of that man we had
i'm gonna let you know uh i gotta i
actually have some show a show in
nashville tomorrow
no thursday night i'm gonna be running
my
uh the hour um
it's gonna be over there at zany's there
may still be tickets available actually
i don't even know if there will be when
this goes up but
just letting you know and then other
places i'm coming to soon huntsville
st louis cincinnati wilkes-barre
minneapolis charleston richmond
baltimore portland burlington
albany buffalo columbus we will be
putting some florida
on the schedule in this for the spring
that'll go up probably in about a month
i think
as well i want to get there to canada if
you guys ever open your country up
so i'll be looking forward to getting up
there and seeing you guys um
what else oh before we get to a lot of
men called in about that first bus they
had
laurel hubbard an openly trans
female weight lifter failed to complete
any of her three lifts at the women's
87 kilogram olympic weightlifting
competition
she's become the first out trans woman
to compete at the olympics
hubbard met all the requirements set by
the iwf but her participation came with
controversy yup
what i think it should i would love to
see and this is just
an idealistic thing
an idea i'll call it
i wish that it was a trade program
you get one we get one we'll send you
ronnie
you send us no
we don't want elizabeth okay we want
diana
you know you send us jacob we'll take
rhondisha like i feel like that
it would be better if there was a
kind of a commission where you got the
trade
where you got the trade and you had to
go all the way through
and live like say if the man that's
coming over he was a postman
and now he wants to work if he switches
at the same time as somebody else to a
different gender that red rover
then they got to be in that person's job
so if you come over
you got to do whatever that you know
that lady was doing
if she's an esthetician now ronnie
is doing nails and feet
you know and sin yum is doing
selling cutco knives or whatever ronnie
was doing i just think i would love to
see
you know red rover red rover send
sharif right over and we will give you
melissa jane
i would love to see that a little bit
more so that you could keep tabs on what
how it's fully working out then you get
the full transition
can you go all the way over can you then
now your uncle is a woman
but can she do the uncle roll does that
make sense riley
it does do you have any trans in your
family
i don't at least
not that i know of right and it's a lot
of hide and go seek out there
you know i thought i've seen somebody
with kind of a long posse before and i
didn't know what it was
but
you know you know you know
you're in your 20s and you just hope god
has a bigger plan for you but
anyway man um yeah that's what's going
on out there
i do feel like the wim
the feminine gender is benefiting more
from this because men we're sending over
some decent men
we've sent over uh
the olympian the decathlete kardashian
uh i don't know what that man's name is
you know his name
i don't we sent that man so you got him
now he's woman out you got him
but who are we getting you know i'd love
us if they would send us somebody
you know send us uh
um oh that lady that played in friday
night lights you know her name
i don't jesus christ man
not you jesus a different guy but
uh never mind i wish that they would
send her over
okay we did it we said a lot um
let's get into these calls man a couple
of calls uh that came in
people that this is we had men calling
and hit the hotline 985-664-9503
talking about the first time they ever
just really jacked out of their body
i want to tell you right now that dinner
time can be
chaotic that's right but with freshly
it's easy their chefs take care of your
meals a few nights a week
and take the pressure off of you we're
all trying to get in shape and eat right
well freshly can help their delicious
meals are designed
by nutritionists and cooked by chefs
you know what chefs are dude
yeah they're making the food
solid people not some [ __ ] lame
the delicious meals are designed by
nutritionists and cooked by chefs making
it easier to eat better
are you stressed you tired you just
don't feel like cooking
who can blame you don't drive to dang
sonic
and sit in the car dad spilled chili on
the steering wheel
freshly offers chef made nutrient-packed
delicious meals delivered fresh to your
door no cooking required
make it easy make it easy they can fit
your lifestyle
a variety of plans and meals to cook
from that work for your dietary needs
preferences tastes and family size
try freshly for six dollars and sixteen
cents per meal
stop searching the internet for healthy
food near me every night
start living freshly imagine just
opening your refrigerator
there it is and it was prepared it's not
manufactured
your meals are always delivered fresh
never frozen ready to eat and enjoy
just heat them up takes three minutes
with new meals added each week
freshly brings the convenience of chef
made nutritionist designed
classics uh right to your kitchen
and right now freshly is offering our
listeners
40 off your first two orders
when you go to freshly.com slash theo
that's right stop stressing about dinner
go to freshly
f-r-e-s-h-l-y
dot com slash theo for 40
off your first two orders that's
freshly.com theo for 40
off your first two orders i got to let
you know what's a country you might
visit man
if you ever could visit somewhere i
would say germany okay
would you ever go back to your homeland
your family's homeland you think
um yeah i'm here
sure buddy what i'm telling you is about
babel okay
the number one selling language learning
app
from ordering in restaurants or asking
for directions to gaining a deeper
understanding of the culture
babble makes the whole process of
learning a new language
addictively fun and easy do you speak
any other languages riley
a little japanese and hawaiian hajime
mash day that's a
little bit of japanese i learned one
time it is
it means our friendship begins
day actually it doesn't really nope
well it did at some point but everything
changes in this new modern society
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go
unlike the infamous language classes you
took in high school babel
designs their courses with practical
real world conversations in mind with
babel you can choose from 14 different
languages
including spanish french italian and
gurman
right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months
for free that's six months for the price
of
three just go to babb el.com and use
promo code theo for an extra three
months free
that's b a b b e l dot com slash theo
it's good to learn new languages huh
yeah
do you find yourself learning more as
you get older or did you feel like you
did a lot of your learning as a youth
um hey i'm learning every day
amen amen man
i want to thank our callers that called
in and offered up some of their stories
let's get into a couple of them
right now these are men in their first
experiences with that first
bust and rather this will all be kind of
new to you but this will be a little bit
of learning experience for you
so listen up yo what up theo this is
your boy beasley god bless man
i'm down here in fayetteville arkansas
beasley
welcome to the show beasley and thank
you for calling from over there in
fayetteville i've been there that's
where bill clinton and his wife started
doing that deal
and uh and it's a beautiful college town
onward about first time we uh
we let that love potion flow well i grew
up in spring i
saw my buddy his name was chris he's a
bird watcher
uh i bet he is dude i bet he is if this
is a
if he's in this story onward uh but
anyway they had an in-ground pool across
the street
so i was probably like sixth or seventh
grade and
i was by the uh by the side of the pool
and that jet
was sitting that winky and uh you know
i didn't even really know what was going
on and so
finally you know
i just did that thing and i didn't even
know what it was
and so uh every day
every day after that i want to go and
swim you know with the
across the street at the neighbor's pool
and
i would just sit there and sit there and
sit there
and finally the mother caught on to what
was going on
and uh i never they never let me back
over there
again and i mean she didn't tell anybody
else what was going on but she
definitely knew what was going on
so that was the first time that that
ever happened
so that's just my story
all right man love you guys gang gang
buzz buzz
gang gang baby love you too man and i
want to say this i would love it beasley
if maybe we could even get that woman's
number and see if you could give her a
call and just clear the air
you know uh i feel like sometimes there
needs to be some air cleared
i got a a man saw me masturbating myself
in a little pool house
in atlanta one time when i was young and
i'll never forget that man and really
what his face looked like
real quickly as he opened the door and
saw me and then closed it back up
that still hurts my heart a little bit
if i'd love to see him if i could
you know if i had time to search you
know show people a picture of this man
until we found him but
but yeah if you can get that lady's
number man we'd love to get her and you
on the line together and see if you
can't
just bring all that to a close brother
you know because i'm sure part of you
still feels bad
you know masturbating into a into their
pool
and and then not even
and then never seeing each other again
that's
that's dicey dude that's almost deadbeat
dad kind of [ __ ] so
let's hear more brother here's another
one that came in thank you beasley
what do you think about what beasley had
to say there riley yeah i mean
i think he feels a little bad
i can just hear it in his voice yep
thank you i can too actually
i like that about you man you're alert
you're right on the cusp baby
hey theo uh you know i just i just
wanted to share with you a story about
the first time
that i ever you know experimented with
uh
you know getting that old semen out of
me ejaculation brother
yes sir tell me more you know what i do
agree with you that should be on the
periodic table of elements
and uh well i was home alone and i was
exploring
you know it was around christmas time i
was looking in the closet
um in my parents closet looking for some
you know christmas presents maybe some
wrapping paper just to get a clue and uh
see this little bottle and it said
something about
hot and cold on it and i squeezed some
in my hand and it smelled good and it
was slippery
and i said you know what i'm gonna go
out in the driveway and sit in that old
saturn that's been sitting there for
about
you know three years so started uh
started rubbing on myself and uh you
know something came out of me
and you know i was probably about 13
years old and uh
you know it felt good i did feel ashamed
though because i knew i wasn't supposed
to be doing
that but i didn't know that was gonna
happen you know it just felt good so i
did
and you know uh i got that hitter
as you told me to i got that hitter gang
baby yeah
the fella right there found a little
special lotion in his folks room and
he's out there pleasuring himself in a
saturn doing hell
doing hand pleasure in a saturn and i'm
sure a lot of people have combed out in
a saturn before i'm not shocked by that
because they even had a discontinuum at
some point
so
what about school dances and stuff riley
when you went to that sort of thing was
there any pressure to be sexually
active or creative in those environments
um not really then again i only went to
a couple of school dances
was it any with like an actual
girlfriend it was more like a setup date
neither it was just with friends oh
really just with the amigos stag huh
man we got to get you out there
all right let's hear another one that
came in right here thank you guys for
these calls and for sharing this part of
your life you know i know it's a unique
time in a man's life
you know when you really when you just
start making those orphans let's hear it
hey theo it's rigged man i'm calling uh
listening
to your latest episode and you're
talking about uh wanting stories
about the first time you spilled the
dumplings
amen rich thank you for calling ridge
amen uh
my first time diddling lord's middle man
and it was in the bathtub
and i was laying in there i'd take long
baths i was about 12 years old and
oh yeah as a pervert baby onward my
little sister
you know we only had two kids in our
house so it was none of that but
she had some barbies and uh
she had the barbies laying out and they
had the smooth pelvis region but
you know my imagination got the best of
me i spilled the dumplings
and uh and then from there on out it was
every night
i was thinking about the neighbors black
sisters and i felt guilty about that but
i've gotten past it and uh but yeah it
was the barbies in the bathtub man
all right gang gang gang baby yeah i
mean look
that's one thing too it can promote
diversity one thing that's neat about
jerk and all for jerking yourself
or spilling your body outside of
yourself is that uh
is that you can fantasize about anyone
and so it can create a lot of uh
diversity in your brain
you know you can really i mean you could
really
pleasure yourself to someone from the
1800s 1600s
you know you could pleasure yourself to
someone from
damn you know 1960s whatever you want
they could be black they could be viet
chinese white
asian german you know
they could be anything bro so there you
go
all right let's hear one or two more
that came in onward
ceo the first time i uh this is david
from baltimore calling it first time i
pleasured myself
i uh i actually didn't do it with my
hands this is a little weird
but there was a hole in the back of this
teddy bear
sure there just happened to be one huh
that old trick that i had that i when i
was a kid there was a
like a hole in the back of it and i kind
of you know
pressed inside it and kept going and
then
when suddenly i got to the point that i
ejaculated
i um i definitely was scared i didn't
know i grew up in a very christian
family no one ever
you know explained to me what semen was
really and so
i really was scared that maybe i had
hurt myself because it was the first
fluid to come out of my body besides
your inner feces or blood
that just really kind of caught me off
guard yeah baby that trick
shot you know that fourth fluid maybe
more
and i definitely uh was nervous
yeah i love you man love you too brother
and yeah
oh what do you think when you hear these
guys rather do you think it's okay do
you think they're wrong or do you feel
like it's just what they're doing what
do you what's going on
um i mean like i said it's
it's what they do if they want to do it
they want to do it yep
can't stop them yep wish we could
sometimes let's hear one more that came
in here here we go
hey theo it's uh xander from indiana
zander thank you for calling and xander
definitely sounds like somebody that's
willing to
jack themselves out a little you know
get all the
jacked up let's hear more bubby just
giving you a call listen to the podcast
you said you want to hear about that
first time ejac story
anyway uh i was in the eighth grade so
it must have been about 12
13. oh yeah and i went on a ski trip for
the class trip and i went off a big jump
and i
landed on my back and i messed it up but
uh
when i got home my mom was telling me to
ice it what not
and she brought out this uh back
massager
you know i was in my bedroom with that
back massager and uh
you know i put it on my penis and a few
seconds later you know i
i creamed out brother did that admission
anyway i didn't know what happened so i
went to my older brother who was about
two years older than me and i showed him
and i was like dude what is this
this came out of me oh he looked at me
go throw those in the garbage and don't
ever tell anyone
that you did that again so i was scared
i was like man
what was that anyway i spent the next
couple months
scared to death to lose any and i
thought that uh if i
if i did it too much that i would run
out and uh i didn't figure out that your
body just keeps pumping that [ __ ] out
until i was about
16 17. so i'm that uh
that private school late learner bro
anyway have a blessed rest of your week
gang gang baby
gang baby huh that he would run out
that's interesting huh
that he would run out that he'd that
there wouldn't be more his brother said
don't tell anybody
go hide it the other kid's making love
to a bear i mean
this is why we are the society we are i
think this is why
we don't know no one knows it there's no
education people are
making love to hold out bears um
people are screwing pool jets uh
you know it there's just
for all the information we have the fact
that we don't
share it to one another blows
my damn nuts out
oh well that's some of them right there
man i remember
i'll share a few with you riley a couple
of my own experiences
you know i remember i was in love with
this gal and
she was pretty good-looking you know she
was probably six out of ten which was
good for me
you know it was good for me she was a
real little thicky bear
and she had real soft titty i remember
that
and i was over at their house one time
and we were sitting back by this
river they had like a river out back or
like a creek or something
and she uh jailed me out into this
stream you know she gave me a handy
or whatever they call it you know just a
wrist just wristing me out into this
little stream and i didn't know i'd
never
like
i'd never just you know pervade semen
out of my body near a uh
anybody else no one had ever else had
seen me do this kind of magic this body
magic
and so next thing you know i e-jacked
out into the stream
and uh these fish swim up
and literally just start consuming it
and so i'm like having dreams
that i'm gonna have like fish that look
like me
in our area you know so i was always
embarrassed to go fishing after that
because i think i always felt like
somehow they would know
like somebody would pull a fish out of
the water and they would hear it you
know like
then the idea would come into their head
because the i the the truth would be in
the fish
so [ __ ] like that will really can really
mess a child up dude
you know it can really
it can really mess a child up but
riley what else man anything else we
want to tell people or talk about
i got a free hot dog from daddy's dogs
oh you did i did
oh wow and how they how how how'd you
get that uh
i was just walking around with a few
friends and uh
someone who was working on working out
the
cart was like riley mao and i was like
hey man what's up he was like dude love
you on the podcast
so he gave me free hot dogs really yeah
shout out to daddy's dogs
damn daddy's dog's hooking people up
with uh
hooking riley up at that nice treat was
it a good dog it was
yeah i love a good dog man
i love them some places i can't eat them
some places i can't eat them
were you guys just walking down the
street yeah amen brother
yeah i love a good dog man
what do you put on yours um
anything onions mushrooms
wash up mustard relish real quinoas yeah
anything damn yeah i like mine i think
i like first i get the dog and the bun
then i like to make a little space
between the dog and the bun
i like to put ketchup on one side
mustard on the other
then i'll go with a relish out that
packet doesn't taste great but
i like what it does
and that's how i'll do mine you know and
i really like to have a diet coke with
if i can
i really like having that diet coke
feeling hit my face after i have the dog
after i have that dog hit my face i like
having that diet coke
you prefer a certain beverage with them
um
either lemonade or dr pepper oh lemonade
okay
i like that
hey pio it's uh cole of san diego man
i've been uh
appreciating the kind of guests we have
on recently on this past weekend
especially the one with
mario gutierrez the jockey went down to
del mar racetrack today and actually got
to see him walk off the
track and call them by name and said i
appreciated the podcast
and i i really enjoyed hearing what he
had to say and
he actually said thank you and
recognized that i
shouted him out so i appreciate it man
it was it was a good podcast and
i bet the money on him will won about 60
bucks so i appreciate it still keep
doing what you're doing i know we all
appreciate it man
gang baby thank you yeah if you haven't
seen that episode
uh it's the jockey episode one of the
job episodes and it's mario gutierrez
and man that was one of my favorite
conversations just
learning about everything about what
it's like to be a jockey
and learning about his trials and coming
from another country
um into into this oppressed horrible
place of america
and being able to live out his dreams
you know i mean how does anybody even do
it
you know how does anybody even do it
um i just there but uh
but no it's a great story and he and
he's just uh
man you just you love him you know and
you love the way that he communicates
and then yeah it gives us somebody to
vent on next time you go to the horse
track
if you're over there santa needed a uh
or i'm not sure some of the other ones
he's at
but yeah down towards san diego i'm
about to get out there and go see him
i'm gonna hit him up soon and get out
there and go see him
but that's the jockey episode mario
gutierrez
and check that one out and i want to
thank everybody just for supporting the
podcast man
and being a part of things here riley i
want to thank you
thank you for being on the uh a part of
the episode today and
and for sharing part of your life with
us and
yeah man it's interesting dude yeah
thanks for having me on
you betcha all right this is a song
every night
by jameson flood
and this song is with us early in the
pod and it's with us here
today you guys be good to yourselves uh
you deserve it
[Music]
gang
[Music]
[Applause]